Yesterday i deleted my video
Lets talk about that
{Good M
this video just got unmonetized (dammit)
don"t worry kjulberg (in sexy Japanese accent)
i'm here (continuing with sexy ass Japanese accent)
To protect you (he keeps the tantalizing accent)
you workin for youtube know (I FUCKIN KNEW IT)
i am making $3000 a month from fans (by selling nudes)
From followers
From viewers
God dam-
What do I call you........
BROS?
I'm gonna try and get these money refunded
I'm not keeping them
Am i...?
Keeping them.....?
Is it wrong for me to keep them?
2 people paid $1000 for me to follow them on twitter
That's fucking inSANE
I didn't fuc-- *stutter*
I didn't realize that
And i'll throw in a nice message like "happy birthday"
Please poke *voice crack* holes for Edgar to breathe
while you ship him here. Thanks!
OH HELL NAAAW
If Edgar arrives dead
That's your problem
My fellow patreons
THIS IS A SCAM
oH no no no
it's not
you do not.. i repeat
you do not need to pay $1
to be able to subscribe
to poopiepie's channel
I was a subscriber before
he opened pateron
don't be like me
and don't fall for the lies
god bless
don't ---
hey
no
Okay
Alright
I *stutter* don't want to just
donate $2000 if people wanted to give me that money
So i'll get it refunded
I'll write to patreon
I don't know
FOUR THOUSAND?!
FOUR.... THOUSAND....
How do-- it must have gone up right now
I swear to God
it was not $4000
Wtf is happening
Oh I see
Patreon takes a lil cut
Yeah, that is pretty slimy
I mean it
You know I could just fukin quit
Youtube and just live off my Patreon now
This is great
hehehe
Well plan B has been sorted guys
Okay um
so yesterdayi deleted my video, and a lot of people freaked out about it
I didn't think it was that big a deal
I just didn't like the video
and a lot of people treated it as if like he is just streesed out
oh my god! (please don't die poodiepie)
i think he is slowly having a meltdown
(that face though)
I've had it since the beggining...OK(sassy)
for me it wasn't that big a deal
I just thought that just a shitty video.(#lowselfasteem)
I don't want to make anymore shitty videos.(I think it's too late now)
I made 3000 videos
OK
let's go through some more deleted videos
I'm actually curious
cuteness over 9000
oh yeah I never uploaded this one
let's see what's wrong with this video
aaaaahhhh...........HOOOOOOO
(OMG is that micheal Jakson. I love him)
(a fucked up micheal jakson remix)pls don't try this at home
(this is how babies are made)
WELCOME
my name is poodiepie
( i have no idea what he said)
this actually is not a bad video
I just didn't
....like it I guess
I deleted that Youtube drama video
remember that time when i said i didn't like drama
and that would cause more drama
than i have ever done
because I'm a major fuckin hypokrit  : (
and now...
I try to hide it by deleting the video
(I GOT MY THUMBS UP BITCHES)
(OBEY THE POODIEPIE THUMB)
this video never made it out
I like how it's called test
WTF is this?
(WARNING: SEIZURES MAY OCCURE INT HIS MOMENT)
(you are a firework pewds)
ok I think i understand what..tsh..tsh(laugh)
(DAAAMMNN those dance moves)
(pewds points at your soul)
(you will never live this down pewds)
(the face of embaresment)
(more dances from peeeewwwwdddiiieeeeppiiieee)
(pewds being dissapointed at his past self)
KHA...HA..HA..OH MY GOD
thank god i didn't show that one on the internet (too late)
jesus christ
how is it going bros my name is pewdiepie
so this one.....wait i uploaded this one?
I think I just played a lot of like mediate,
very poorly made horror games.
*zooms in on face* And I DIDNT LIKE IT.
See I-I'm all about the quality o-on my channel :I
GUYS I'm sooo picky with whatever goes up
*Pauses*
Has to be the finest of the fine -im like a fine wine, baybay
You just gotta sip on it a lil' bit (wth)
Gotta make it- *COMMENCE WEIRD KISSING NOISES WITH HANDS*
pewds just stop.
Thats-thats the poodiepie channel *a few more weird hand kisses for good luck*
i quit life.
Just think of like a-like a 50 year old man with a moustache and glasses (You?)
Justa,
NICE
Justa gets a little bit (what did he just say)
*Weird thing with tongue* gahgah a little bit
VAPOUR I never uploaded-this is a really cool horror game
BUT WHAT HAPPENED?! what went wrong (you?)
*weird poodiepie noises*
OH COME ON BAYBAY
This is a mix of frustration and terror, but I hope you bros enjoyed it regardless.
You can tell I didn't enjoy playing this
And I think that just shows so well
And I don't wanna do this type of video.
Like, i dont know if im gonna like the video before- the game- before I play it - poodiepie 2016
I think that's why I don't really do that much gameplay anymore
Because I don't really know if i'm gonna like the game before I play it
That can be really frustrating and I dont really have that much time-I know
I'm a very busy man (you?)
Gotta lot of stuff to do but I really DONT HAVE THAT MUCH TIME TO RECORD EVERY SINGLE DAY
JUST PLAY GAMES EVERY SINGLE FUCKING DAY (jesus calm down)
IM SORRY I DON'T HAVE TIME FOR
EVERYONE IS JUST COMPLAINING
Why doesn't he not play more games (yh why?)
*mega zoom in on that face* I WILL play more games if good games comes out :D great grammar poods
Have you thought about that? (no)
UNCHARTED was a great game you enjoyed that shit didn't you? (Yup)
Don't you wanna wait for good games :I no
Or do you rather wanna see me play shitty games all the FUCKING time (yes)
Because im TIRED of it
Im TIRED of all these too many shitty games (good lord calm down)
Markiplier - plays games all the time
Jacksepticeye - plays games ALL the time.
Diamond minecraft? - plays minecraft every single day
Do you think he doesn't wanna suicide (damn)
Do you think he wanna keep on living, this horrible life?
Do you think he wanna make these faces for the thumbnails? (yea)
Toby games - do you think he wants to do 400 parts of happy wheels?!
Why do you think he does drugs? (you do it too)
But no, it's not enough for you
MORE GAMES (YEAH)
MORE HAPPY WHEELS (UMM YEA)
LOOK WHAT YA DID!
Do you think oprahhackssirnoah wants to make these faces every day?
DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT?
Michonne
That game was so SHIT
And I played through the whole fucking thing?
*weird rape noise* My life is sooo HARD (sure)
*giggles*
Okay, im gonna play more games, if I uhh wanna play the games
I think thats the problem, a lot of the times.
You can make the video more entertaining by editing it and adding funny memes
But at the end of the day,
You can't hide how fucking hard you're trying
To make it interesting.
And that is this video, that I deleted yesterday.
And its entirely *laughs*
*Intense focus on that game*
OHHH HOLY SHIT
I TOLD YOU
WHAT'D YA HAVE TO SAY
Now lets check out some more videos I deleted
Why did I delete this? (I dunno poods)
I did not delete this.
You should read the title. Jack is in it *looks of disappointment*
That makes sense (yes)
*Intense stare at screen*
Da fuq is this
What is this beautiful piece of art work?
Actual looks of disapointment.
But seriously tho, wat is that?
Oh gad.
What the fuck are you doing? dude
oh man those are some hilarious faces you're pulling there :S
*pewds scarred for life*
Oh bo-ho-y
oh the tongue. NOT THE TONGUE.
*Old pewds mumbling bs*
I can't, no i can't (same)
i-im sorry i can't watch this shit
i-i would rather die (me too)
I-i would rather die :3
This is a video, I did just for Marzia (awww)
Somehow some other people had found it :I yes pewds you've figured out how to yt
*Really awkward and cringy but cute pewds*
Old pewds sounding like he just broke his voice: Hey Marzia, umm you must think I only have like 2 shirts or
Real time pewds: No that's private
we used to send video messages aw that's a good memory *he said as he smiled away*
Look how- look how cute I looked before (cause you aren't anymore)
No wonder I got Marzia :)
Yeah bring the dog in there
Nice move Felix :D
oh, no not that one
Why am I playing a gameplay in the background of a gameplay? (gameplay inception!)
Answering questions - unedited - for 20 minutes...
And why do I have the same fucking hair cut now! *facepalm*
Jesus Christ.
My old-
Maybe you didn't know this but I started off doing COD gameplay (MORE GAMES?!)
"Poodiepieee"
Did the intro even back then
Ya alright poods?
pewdiepie having a heart attack in the background, as usual.
Someone help him.
What a dramatic way of dying.
OMG HE CAME BACK ALIVE
Old pewds mumbling some more random, uhhh, stuff.
Old pewds: I'll ever see, i've ever seen anyone else
I don't think gah
Present pewds back again: Yeah no one else has gotten a toy 6-26 3kd pewdiepie
You're definitely the only one in the fucking universe
To be fair it was a gun game though and I was pretty fucking bomb ass at it
Look at this fucking last kill i remember I was so fucking proud :3 okay im sorry calm down
look at dis.
Proud pewdiepie: Hell yea, HELL YEAH
You couldn't pull that shit off to save your fucking life :3 cause im too busy saving yours
Yeah my fucking just dance videos
I was so proud of these
Because everyone did the same thing on yt back then(and still do)
Like for me to play just dance was like woah (your dance skills tho)
This guy thinks outside the BOX
Really, REALLY awkward laugh.
Im sweating x2
This is pain- you don't understand how painful this is (i know)
There's some videos with fucking 500 views :O
"It's poooodiepieee"
Poods sweating hard
The coolest background music like ever
guy in the game: FIRST BLOOD
Good meme :D
Bomb background music continues...
MLG pro
*Little laugh of disappointment while shaking head*
Nice song pick Felix. nice.
Hilarious. Good meme pewdiepie.
Okay I had the whole series of blank dream
I never published it.
I forgot about it
It's a good game (FINALLY)
Pewdiepie singing amazing, as usual.
Really good singing Felix. Consider going on x factor once
Real looks of disgust.
Get ready for the the big drop.
RIP headphone users
You know, this is a great example of when people say my videos were better before.
Yeah, I dont know anymore.
My very first video
And it's not actually up on my channel (yeah i didnt notice)
And this is my very first video.
Poods with a very strong Swedish accent so I don't understand a word he's saying...
OOOOHH, my Swedish accent is so strong!
pewds mimicking Swedish accented pewds: I haven't ler-learnt it yet, sorry.
Swedish accented pewds: I haven't learnt it yet sorry
Pewds: Sorry im Swedish, uhh i have-haven't learnt how to do uh YouTube yet tehehehe
He said that he was top of the leaderboardz and zombies and uhh
I am uhh poopeepie
Pewds continuing to mimic accented pewds: welcome to my video.
You know in like 5 years im gonna be here again reacting to this video and cringing equally.
WHAT CAN I SAY
YouTube is a beautiful thing.
Oh hey!
Urghhh
Well I should-
Kill yourself.
*tuts* oh shit I remember this.
PEEWWDEEPIEE
I thought it was so cool.
How Hutch and Seananners and Sark were like talking about me.
That was just like
Well I made it now boyss
*claps* Im in the big league NOWW
Thank you very much.
So yeah, I have a ton of videos deleted
And I'm gonna delete a lot more
So don't worry about it (okay)
I'm just at the point where I've gotten more out of YouTube than I ever wanted.
That was not correct.
More than I ever expected.
From now on I feel like if I don't put out stuff that i'm happy with,
then what's the point? You know?
Thats really uhh my main focus
I don't care about more subscribers, I don't really care about all the rest of bull shit.
Just wanna make videos that I feel happy with (this is getting emotional)
so thank you for understanding that, and I hope this video explained it.
Leave a like for more likes because I do really care about those :D
And i'll see you bros in the next video, as always.
*kisses fist* In Swedish accent: BROFIST
It's a pretty good bargain.
For $5 you get this roomscape image
I think thats a pretty good offer.
$7, if you pledge 7 dollars you get Edgar
Alright just take him
You know what? He's free. I don't want him.
Get out of it. What are  you doing?
I need more ideas. For patreon.
Ainsley with an accent: You should use look at other peoples profiles and do what they do.
I should just look at other people's profiles and do wat they do?
GENIUS! LET'S DO THAT!